nous disons non à d'autres meurtres
arrêter le génocide en kart la main des
centaines de chrétiens ont exprimé leur
douleur ce dimanche une communauté
meurtrie par des violences dans le
centre du nigeria dernière attaque en
date le 24 juillet dernier
cette nuit là dix personnes sont tuées à
kafanchan toute chrétienne
parmi les victimes un enfant de 5 ans un
pasteur et une personne âgée
onze autres sont également blessés et
des maisons incendiées pour dire stop au
massacre l'association chrétienne du
nigeria a appelé ses fidèles à se
rassembler des prières et des chants
pour faire sortir du silence le
gouvernement
notre gouvernement est vraiment resté
muet après ces meurtres
le gouvernement devrait déjà se lever et
intervenir l'appareil de sécurité
devraient être engagés pour chasser ces
bandits les tueries auraient vraiment dû
cesser les violences continuent de se
produire
il n'y a pas d'engagement sincère de la
part du gouvernement je peux rappeler
aux gens que l'état de kaduna pu
maintenir la paix pendant neuf ans de
novembre 2002 à avril 2011
il n'y a pas eu de violence dans notre
état certaines personnes peuvent-elles
simplement aller demander pourquoi que
se passe-t-il aujourd'hui pour que nous
soyons à nouveau la cible de ces
attaques sans fin au cours de ces sept
derniers mois 180 membres de la
communauté chrétienne ont été tuées dans
l'état de kaduna la ceinture centrale du
nigeria est secoué par un conflit de
longue date entre agriculteurs et
éleveurs l'état de kaduna est devenu
aussi ces dernières années un repaire de
bandits spécialisé dans le vol de bétail
et les enlèvements contre rançon des
violences entre bergers peuls et paysans
sédentaires auxquels s'ajoutent des
attentats terroristes menées par boko
haram ou y soit factions de dèche des
groupes radicaux qui ont provoqué en dix
ans la mort de 36 mille personnes au
nigeria et fait 2 millions de déplacés
sur tout le territoire